Oh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
yeah yeah yeah yep what's that what up
Tony I'm doing good how you doing I'm
good you know I feel you just weird to
speak to you
even though been hanging out for the
past hour
[Laughter]
yeah it's like put on a recording
persona yeah how's it going man already
had a full conversation yeah it caught
up caught up but this isn't this is
necessary we gotta go in because the
people word and listen they didn't they
didn't hear that part so you have to
greet each other but it's fine that's
fine
we're here at the Chicago theater
Chicago theater as you can see yeah [ __ ]
is beautiful I just I love performing at
this venue it means a lot that marquee
man that's a cago theater marquee man
you like that placement huh that just in
general well just I'm known about the
outside party yeah the outside part
that's class it looks first time my name
was on that joint you know I was I was
pretty excited we made it it just felt
it felt good
yeah like I was always like reluctant to
have my parents come to any other shows
but when we did this when we were doing
that Chicago theater right I was like
okay this is the show you could come see
me yeah they're like they know it's it's
a it's institution sir is is landmark
it's a goddamn historical place
everybody's been through this [ __ ] yep
3400 seats or 3,600 depends on who you
ask
you got earth wind fire earth win
Melissa Etheridge Stephen Dan yo without
that well you don't say to end it sounds
weird when I don't say that what the end
and it's Earth Wind and Fire that's what
I said
no you said earth wind fire oh that I
yeah it sounded weird I don't think I've
ever heard anybody say like that in my
entire life I didn't even realize yeah
went via and I was I was triggered here
lost I was that that hit me harder than
a racial slur Wow I apologize no
apologies Hannibal no apology doesn't it
earth wind fire Earth Wind and Fire
that's a smooth as name no oh yeah it's
a pretty good night it matches their
persona and music very well yeah I
wonder how they came up with that name
so what should we go with earth I'm
earth I feel Earth Wind and Fire that's
a [ __ ] hell of a name mmm how do you
think they were that sound like some hi
Sid do that weird a weird ain't known
for getting down like that I don't
really know much about the individuals I
can't even name the members members yeah
Earth Wind and Fire I can't either
and I couldn't if I saw them on the
street I could but I know the name and I
know the mute I know that they're
legendary one of those they are they one
of your favorite classic bands from back
in the days I don't know we got the they
might be one of those where I know a
couple of the songs and I know I
definitely know a couple of the songs
and then they probably had some other
songs yeah that are part of the culture
that I don't even realize it when
somebody knows that's Earth Wind and
Fire oh [ __ ] or probably rappers have
sample to show they've been sampled yeah
and it's certain things that uh
yeah what do you think your favorite
soul like old-school soul band is of all
time or singer uh I don't know school
yeah I don't know I don't know we got we
got our guest here this is the actual
podcast we roll it man let's do it we
would just bullet do a [ __ ] filler
talk you know I thought you the one guy
I thought that was too cool to have a
podcast I guess podcasts are cool down
podcast is just a good it's a good
outlet man and for a four-second I
fought it I fought it I've been fighting
it all right I fought off I was like no
I'm not gonna do what I wasn't gonna do
what there's a line in top five it's
just a little like I'm walking in the
club and I think somebody goes hey man
can you do my podcast like yeah yeah but
you know I apartment because we do stuff
like this and we this is a this is an
organelle in front of you Chris
so organelle I'm reading the poster over
there okay
July night Bill Maher's yeah I think
that's all yeah that's all poster Wow
oh that's from your last time it must be
my last tour yeah because it's
definitely not July tonight just shows
you how hard it is to break in the show
business cuz most of those people are
still doing gigs Steely Dan earth water
fire Bill Maher huh yeah I'm but I'm
just saying like if you're a young act
you'd figure 8 10 years later I wouldn't
be here so you know I mean like that
could be like a lineup tomorrow Melissa
after its shame been through the sky
recently
okay but she still got the pole you
still got the pole well even that just
for less is that old that's 2011 Wow and
it's still like look at that right louis
c.k i was at that louis c.k Demetri Mar
and I was on I was on that Demetri
Martin show I was one of the
the special guest it's like wow it's
hard to break into show business because
it's the same because that could be the
lineup right now yeah that's true it's
not hard to breakable you really you
really accomplished something
you really did something that a is tough
Massillon sent you a video imagines like
this guy's really funny can write jokes
yeah
you reached out I wrote some stuff I've
worked on some stuff with you what you
like late night stuff okay yeah yeah
watch shows and [ __ ] some stuff like
that brought some jokes put a couple
grand in my pocket it was very exciting
hey check the check I got a check for a
couple grams from the Chris Rock
enterprises I was like yeah hey
unexpected couple thousand dollars I see
in 2010 that was hey I will pay for help
I have no problem asking for help and I
try to pay I try to overpay a little bit
right just so when I call people pick up
right you know yeah it's like you go to
barber shop yeah I get a guy hundred
dollars every time
really cuz I don't want to ever wait in
a shop you know do you have but you have
a bar become to you
well barber come to now lately I got a
guy I text them he's got a shop yeah
it's cool shop you got to be in a shop a
little bit for the vibe to see yeah yeah
you gotta be in shop a little bit but uh
he cuts jay-z and Pharrell so you know
you got a shop in Harlem or Brooklyn and
Brooklyn and not in Jersey in Jersey
Jersey but you know sometimes they take
them like you're stuck you have to cut
your own hair I'm in Dusseldorf you know
with with Timberland okay I guess I
can't well you gonna do for the overseas
because you bout to head to Europe right
I'm about to head to Europe yes
whatever you're Barbara sees wasted in
your
like a we got a problem two weeks so
I'll probably just get a cut right
before I go and hopefully it'll last did
you last time in Europe was the previous
tour the the I remember was called tour
not bigger and blacker it was for the
especially with the three cities yes
with the the killed a messenger killed a
messenger
yes I got it that win an Emmy for
editing or and want to Emmy fattening I
work with that guy Michael Michael
Schultz yeah
black editor yeah there you go not to be
confused with Michael Schultz who
directed Cooley high I mean that's heavy
trivia right there
did uh have you been to these clubs you
going to Norway on this I'm going to
know I haven't been in Norway no never
I'm playing Dubai and playing a bunch of
spots I've never been a Dubai you get it
is weird get it while it's hot I went I
went to Dubai his weird over there
what's weird about it what's the money
the money aspect is weird where the the
Royal is a lot of oil money Prince I
went to my hotel that I was staying at
it was just nothing but Lamborghinis and
Ferraris out front
like seven eight and royalty has the the
people that are from oil money have
specific license plates is where people
will point out like the drivers like all
that that like means that they're a
prince it's on the nicest place Wow
yeah it's incense but he's a pretty can
smack your mother oh okay thanks for
coming on the show man I'm excited
Chicago yes my hometown Chicago my book
great Hannibal Buress larell Bernie Matt
Bernie Mac Kanye West chance to rapper
yeah that's it Michael Jordan Brock
Obama Oprah rim three you know political
corruption Al Capone
Kapaa home simplest syphilis started
here we syphilis curable I don't know
I'm us oh they're all curable by not
[ __ ] yeah I think I think you get
like some antibiotics or something that
think it's one of those kind of joints I
don't want to find out what one thing I
noticed from you know we've done shows
together but during the tour dates yeah
who knows how meticulous you are about
the set where it's really it's a set
ways from top to bottom will you really
you you work it and you run through it
every day just you me right before I get
on stage before and after yeah I go
through it I go like okay is this joke
really poppin is there more here did I
miss it's all about getting that special
ready so right yeah it's yeah when I'm
in the clubs yeah every night at yeah I
don't even know what I'm going to say
half the time right but I people are
paying a hundred bucks or whatever the
hell they're paying yeah gotta give them
I'll be nice if I had an idea that's all
it's uh it's exciting man he's excited
there's the we talked about it what
doing dates together I mean I called you
years ago yeah you was you kept on yeah
I'm not the tour you always just about
the tour I could never pull the trick
yeah you do that yeah I'm about to do
this couple stress factory dates and so
he could play the comedy club didn't go
on tour yeah it sounds good and you like
he's gonna be me yeah we did a couple of
those yeah we did a couple dos it was
fun
how far are in the tour are you right
now I am let's see I did about 61 dates
already yeah I got 39 more that's like
back to back back like that a hundred
dates a warrior I'm so hundred dates man
warrior okay and I just got divorced so
I lost a lot of money I'm trying to yeah
the recouped it's the recoup their rate
that's a tough week that's a that's a
that's older man thoughts and just
different situate the situations that I
haven't like heavy situations I haven't
been in did I've been in some [ __ ] but
that's heavy when you just when you just
see to offer and then you just have to
split it in your head all right yeah I
got a bill I have a big bill to pay I
lost a lot of money and you know what I
was back last night to get here but not
about you bounce back bounce back it's
not like I don't know money I dunno it's
just that you know what it is when you
have dough in show business it just
gives you the ability to turn things
down right just like ah get the [ __ ] out
of my face
and when you broke it's like okay tell
me more about the game show right so
yeah okay you know who am i the
announcer how many contestants are there
you know it's like you don't even have
that conversation when you're you know
what I brag about to people what my I
got a low overhead overheads the
pre-hire
it's only a couple more years my kids
will be in college yeah that'll cut my
child support a little bit it's all just
be paid alimony you know it's all of you
right low overhead overhead
whenever I see guys doing really
horrible stuff I'm gonna high over it
I'd say that's the same thing we're like
what why is he doing that you're like oh
yeah baby mamas and of course he's doing
that yeah but if you can keep it low you
can be fly forever you could never do
any wack [ __ ]
that's what I yeah I want to do all my
wack [ __ ] by choice not by necessity
it's an accident of course you're gonna
accidentally do some [ __ ] that turns out
wack Hey yeah I did Angry Birds cuz I
wanted to didn't need to me was I was no
president I did osmosis jones you know
as Moses Jones I didn't know the the
concept what was the concept I was like
ooh blood cell inside some fat guy's
body and so it was about his body just
like fighting it was almost like I was a
detectives trying to solve the crime of
why this guy was sick yeah whatever
decided to take that role uh it was the
Farrelly Brothers yeah he directed it so
you know dumber dumber and so about Mary
did it uh not come together well or was
it just they perform well um I think it
was okay I mean here's the thing I think
what their movies I mean their movies
are good don't get me wrong but they're
probably 50% performance where 50%
writing and animation honestly is like
70 80 % writing right and twice you
could put people in it
and they'll my trip for the most part is
gonna work
yeah if your dad was in it yeah Pixar
Disney those scripts are ridiculously
tight and they have they take amazing
twists and turns and you know I mean
like this they're obviously the best
scripts in the world so really just fine
right if it was a movie who wasn't
animated who knows about have been a hit
if it was just me as a cop solving a
crime yeah probably but it how many
drafts of top five did you do drafts the
top five I don't know 15 20 I mean I was
writing all the time it was like I mean
to sell it probably about five right
like okay well I finally like took it to
Scott Rudin was like hey what do you
think about this but throughout the
process was writing all the time like
every weekend okay what am i shooting
next week all right let me make sure
these scenes are perfect but instead I
fly you know some I am an ad or
something
hey it happens you just gotta let life
happen bounce back
oh no sorry about that what's the next
special gonna be called tambourine
tambourine yeah oh because of the I
don't spoil yeah I get yeah tambourine
right yeah that's the name right it's a
tent it's uh it's a slight it's a dig
[Laughter]
something we should all aspire to its
tambourine went and you filming in New
York I'm filming them Brooklyn that so
BAM in that small room like six hundred
you doing this six on it yeah yeah Wow
okay will you bring the pains in 600 I
came the bring
it's like 600 or so you prefer to do it
in a more intimate setting I just think
this set I'm doing now requires a more
intimate setting you know I mean there's
some places like when when Pryor did
live on the Sunset Strip and he's doing
the whole thing about Africa and I don't
see any [ __ ] can't do that in an arena
yeah you know I mean like it required
everyone to be paying attention so I got
some moments in this special that
require people to pay attention the last
special I did was [ __ ] three
countries right it's crazy so take it
down you know has anyone ever done a
special I get the cellar not at the sign
I mean the councilman did a little small
special I think somebody filled in
Village Underground recently the other
cellar room yeah in the in the in the in
the side room Nate somebody's done
something that's hard doing it it sounds
like a great idea but the reality is you
need way more material and ice room that
small well is that because when you're
yeah in front of 3,000 people the laughs
are so big wrong yeah like when I'm on
when I'm working outfit or 45 minutes in
a club I'm like okay let's go yeah yeah
because I know 45 minutes is going to be
an hour in a theater when you when you
film this one huh you're gonna you
planning for any adjustments in the
approach well you know like you said
like you perform you know when you're
playing here Chicago thing look will you
do things bigger or will you in the
timing would it be any adjustment you
just gone I mean I'm gonna have to speak
I'm not you know I'm gonna have to
really work my voice in a different way
the screaming is gonna have to like be
at a minimum guys like
really control it like like I don't know
when I was young and I want used to
watch Sam Kinison when he was when he
wasn't that famous he was actually
funnier because he was playing to
smaller houses and his screams would be
it was something he would use sparingly
right but then as he got to be this big
thing it was just like you know I'm
trying to take it back telling that take
it back
did you work with him before can you um
you know I know yeah yeah I know I was I
met Kinison I was at catch a rising star
it's old club before your time New York
New York Upper West Side Upper Upper
East Side Reese and I was on stage I was
like an open mic or whatever the [ __ ]
you want to call it like clubs used to
be open tonight damn it at 2:00 in the
morning back then it was you it what 18
19 and I'm doing some joke about my
brother and freebasing or something like
some the middle of the crack epidemic so
I'm doing some crack jokes
it wasn't really about my brother but
was just about free basing anyway and
only one person's laughing in the back
and it's Sam Kinison laughing his ass
yeah you know laugh laughing like DeNiro
and Cape Fear like he throws the
funniest [ __ ] ever
and he's like kid he's introduced
himself as how he knew he was I already
watched it mache so yeah yeah when I
hang out took me to hang out with them
[ __ ] and I met Robin Williams Widow oh
wow it is like Oh tomorrow is that what
are you doing Saturday I'm like I'm
gonna hang out and hopefully maybe try
to get on if nobody shows up you know do
makeup spots cuz you said makeup spots
for yeah they should be like a show
would be booked and then there be a
backup comic in case nobody came the
backup would go on yeah cuz even
somebody was late
they couldn't even really call they just
was just best people just really miss
[ __ ] so kinnison's like go I'm doing
Saturday Night Live you should come
sure yeah so I come with Sam Kinison to
do science hosted no no he was doing
comedy he said yeah they used to have
like they stopped comedians yeah and he
was he was doing he was Spike Lee was da
no malcolm-jamal Warner was the host it
was like it's such a weird coincidence
that I he invited me to this show right
and Run DMC was a musical guest Wow Wow
so and I mean enables really Run DMC
yeah they did
they did hit it run long over here hit
it run the the record where runs on the
beatbox and it's all DMC yeah oh it's so
great oh do you really believe what's
going on DMC deep seas the most
underrated rapper ever
hey everybody gives run prop like DMC
was amazing anyway and so and spiked in
a short film it was like the craziest
blackest S&L ever and Sam
I watched Sam do a set he did some joke
about Jesus's last words I'm not trying
to make jokes about Jesus though I saw
the movies I read the Bible he's always
on the cross at the end of the
crucifixion there's always 30 or 40
Christians standing around going it's a
shame and Jesus is always going
but the Bible said you're supposed to
die
ah tough gig tough gig oh you like he
really knew how to use his uh I watched
him snort coke right before he went on I
how many lines like to three to three
lines I watched him do coke right before
you offer me I was like not tonight
you know later on I would say yes but
and so weird and then he goes out and he
does this joke he wasn't supposed to do
the Jesus joke
they told him not to and he still did
and he's still dead it's live TV so they
cut the joke in LA oh you know and I
remember riding with him down the
elevator it's like well [ __ ] it
he acts so cool but he really loved
being famous and he was it was like it
was just happening for him and I
remember being in the elevator with Sam
use like anybody got a pen I got a pen
people are looking for a pen thinking he
needed to write something down somebody
finally gave him a pen and it was
basically just so cuz he knew he had to
sign autographs when he got outside yeah
he was thinking about signing autographs
yeah Sam [ __ ] Kinnison no yeah
that's when I started talking with you
while I was writing at SNL and I
remember you actually had called me and
was doing a rewrite session on a
Thursday and I just step out of the
rewrite room you just I lecturing me for
20 minutes
well yeah you just told me to get on
camera
oh yeah cuz I was right in Ulan get I
was on camera who the [ __ ] these
[ __ ] update and so then from
that
I've met with Seth Meyers and said hey
man I wanna at this point I had been
getting zero sketches on as a writer so
simply so this is definitely just a
weird move just to be yeah man I know
everything kid sketches on but put me on
Weekend Update let me I want to do some
bits anything like okay and so we did
and so we put together like that we
framed where I was a financial advisor
and I we put some of my jokes in pickle
juice and this thing about rental car
windows windshield wiper and we did that
in Weekend Update at the dress rehearsal
but then they cut it for the show even
though it killed that but they let me
they gave me a shot off of that so thank
you for that sometimes he's got a push
hey I knew you is funny and you know
other people on the show really you
writing for these [ __ ] so be at
the time it worked out for you
everything worked out
Eustace no [ __ ] DJ named my DJ name my
first DJ name was whiplash yeah why
that's a good DJ name whiplash and then
I went to Chris Rock yeah that's so
Chris Rock my name is Chris Rock saucony
after Kurtis Blow you go oh I can just
be Chris Rock really so you were DJ it
was a it was whiplash was it Chile see
maybe Shelley see ya might have been
Chile see because you had these
different personas yeah I would spin
what these guys called the rock freak
crew they were all older than me they
were all older than me
and we play block parties and weddings
and [ __ ] and use people's you know one
guy had a mixer and this mother's
turntable and that mother's turntable
and hey let's put our money together and
get an amp
you know that sort of [ __ ] when arrow
was this goddamn it I would say guess
all the wrong 15 16 oh [ __ ] yeah yeah I
guess yeah I was saying so in 75 I was
10 so yeah like 1980 yeah yeah yeah he
was playing like breakbeats
yeah I was a gold yo man I used to go to
the Music Factory in Times Square
disappear music this would be this
record store in the train station right
in Times Square
and you would brought you by breakbeats
and you would see it wasn't like there
was a bunch of places to buy breakbeat
so you might actually see you know kid
Creole from the Furious Five in there or
you know you know flash whoever you know
you would see all these guy I've been to
the disco fever I scratch Apache and
[ __ ] freedom and you know you spent
80 funky ping like yeah I'm like but
mostly like funk that right no man I'm
talking breakbeats
[Music]
catch like I can name if you played
records right now I go okay that is
that's like what's the beat from Eric
being rock him paid and painful don't do
it
none that was to drum be anyway it's the
same drumbeat is really familiar with it
that's a that's a record called roach
clip okay like I know the record yes for
a lot of these records a lot of the
sound you hear I go no no no that's from
rocket in the pocket that's so long
that's a row
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
that's funky penguin that's Apache
that's impeach the president's on a
thousand records not sample just another
sample yeah yeah like I know the
original record that they're sampling
from there's a lot of other beats that
you like really they use that all the
time yeah there were like those classic
break beat halls that everyone used or
chop it up and turn the drum kit I
remember I remember when we when we all
found out that Billy Squier big beat was
just the greatest speed ever and it
wasn't like a hit record so you could
barely get it in New York it's just like
[ __ ] buying 210 I need ten Billy
Squires right now yeah cuz you don't
know that you scratch the [ __ ] out yeah
yeah once you get cuz then they start
sounding dusty yeah and once you wear
them out so then you got to get another
copy if I really like a vinyl I'll get
like five copies ahead of yeah yep you'd
have like us you'd have a practice vinyl
that you just used to practice then you
have show like you know stuff okay I got
a black party Saturday I'm gonna use the
real the good ones have you thought
about getting back into it I have
thought about getting back into it I'm
good friends with print prints Paul so
and whenever he spends in New York he
lets me know and I go and I'll spin for
like 50
oh yes yeah yeah rusty yeah people are
like is that Chris Rock amen there's a
money on the table for celebrity DJs I
pick up I pick up a couple grand here
and there and I'm not good at all I
don't blame ya it's seeing you up there
Chris prices up there play music that's
though it's people yeah it's fun man
but we bring the theremin in and the
idol tune and we do crazy yeah we get
weird over here man you know this is uh
you know yo are you making a record you
never made a record like a album like a
Rambabu well that's a comedy slash I
have crazy ideas that probably shouldn't
be on television right yeah this is that
pretty much this is that this is where
we really get where's yours and your no
sex in the champagne room oh I got a
couple songs
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
- hey was up yeah I want to send a big
shout out to our newest sponsor Toro
Toro
it's Airbnb for cars you know you if you
hate shuttle buses Toro is for you if
you hate long lines and like convenience
Toro is a great app I've actually used
it a couple times while I'm traveling
and in Chicago just to drive some cars
and I wouldn't be able to drive weld it
out they ask Tesla's on there they got
some crazy ass cars they also get your
asses and Ford escorts and stuff like
that I don't kid in the Ford Escort was
discontinued a while ago and they
probably wouldn't allow it on the Toro
platform anyways I like the app you can
rent cars from people they bring the car
to you or you go pick it up it's a
smoother transaction it's great you
could pick the exact car you want if you
say hey I want a Nissan you can set the
filters for a Nissan you know sometimes
you go to one of the rental car places
and then they just assign you your
garbage car and you just take it like a
punk that's not happening with turbo you
pick your exact car and you've written a
car from a individual is theirs they
personally connected to your happiness
all bs aside Rambler listeners it's a
solid app should try it out if you want
to try it out when you travel this all
over the world people are hosting with
their cars go to Toro con tu Roo promo
code Hannibal get riding I'm trying to
create a catchphrase get in right right
drive drive
[Music]
where's your cookie in the butt where's
your
it's just sound beautiful man
that's it see it plays itself it's
beautiful show business yeah that's what
we do we just do that yeah that's how we
cover up that we bad at interview it no
sex in the champagne room was when that
was was that 99 let's see when this
bring okay bring the Paynes 96 no sex in
the champagne room I don't know what
that is like the second album or
something I don't know it's like in the
probably around 99 yeah who was featured
on there gerald levert
[Laughter]
[Music]
Joubert just happened to be in the
studio upstairs that was this we we
recorded that now we recorded it at what
the hell's the name of the studios the
same spot to pop that shot so we said
literally it's Midtown right yeah yeah
so why am I forgetting right now anyway
and yeah so old dirty bastards on the
album yeah he was just happy to be
upstairs recording and we got him on a
sketch did this thing called the words
of wisdom by the old dirty bastard
yeah you hear that [ __ ] what is he like
what was your party party without Artie
with ODB on my record he's so high that
we had a sketch for him to do and he
couldn't it was just so [ __ ] up but he
was on the mic for like 12 minutes just
saying [ __ ] so we took that stuff me and
my man a little Roy and we edited it
down and we
once again words of wisdom from the ODB
and for [ __ ] had the power to shrink
itself
what would you action that was words of
wisdom with the ODP he didn't know he
did that right you could tell on the
second album that he was in the studio
talking Wow and they chopped that up
hey Chuck I'm on that out please
upstairs house downstairs
oh did a train okay Ellen and Chad was
there they make miracles happen with
that because you could hear the cuts you
can order albums so amazing but it's
great yeah they made kind of amazing
underrated record yeah it is
I agree 100% oh man yes he was in there
I got ice cube this whoever wasn't I've
picked that studio because I knew all
the rappers came through there yeah so
strategy always hear about that though
such a such just happened to be in the
other room and then they came in oh this
[ __ ] is hot and then they just started
birth yeah who you isn't it - now who am
i listening to him you know Kendrick DUP
Jake hold up who so did you see last uh
you know I loved it it's not a rapper
but uh my man Frank ocean's show is
amazing yeah it's what you saying this
huh
I saw him at that festival not too long
ago in LA my F F F laughs oh yeah yeah
yeah yeah okay I saw you like in a
distance or some [ __ ] I played there
yeah I didn't I didn't stay I didn't see
Frank cuz I was too high and I'd left
already
I think I think I said when I saw you
you were really [ __ ] up an outsider
leave him alone
this is not the time to bother Hannibal
hey man I'm the older comedian that
we're kind of friendly with hey if
there's people I know I'm fine with it
when strangers are like yo let's take a
picture
hey do you see my eyeballs right now
come on let me just have this
interaction that's not documented it up
yeah yeah what your friend you you you
even famous what 20-some years hello but
this is sight I was in New Jack city
ever every rapper talks about the Carter
I was really in the Carter I I smoked
crack in the Carter [ __ ] I try
to kick me I think you've seen it sir I
have a t-shirt there's a black shirt in
this picture you as Pookie hey actually
I think I've worn that shirt when I've
done so you know I remember one time
when I was on acid I liked my first
month or whatever I don't know what I
had a really good show long story
Eddie Murphy comes to see me yeah and I
had an Ernie Murphy raw poster standing
next to a raw poster yeah basically
giving me the same talk I gave you like
you gotta get on the end you gotta do
and I say okay I'm playing myself after
taste Susie lapin take it down yeah take
it down
I wish I hadn't taken it down I wish I
still owned it cuz it was [ __ ] a cool
ass poster yeah cool like anywhere free
raw kept it up man that he came to the
show and took me in Tim Meadows to lunch
is like hey black guys come with me
as fairly so [ __ ] up John Belushi came
by and just took the white guys and left
me hey sailors Farley come on you would
have Rock you stay he would have a heavy
lunch bill though his bill way bigger
than his bill it was like Tim Meadows
first day - he's like what uh what do
you think happened with you that where
you you're you weren't having to push
your ideas forward or I mean good time I
got some stuff on between people you
know people sometimes people make a big
deal of it much on
I mean SNL SNL's like a weird show it's
like it's really hip on some levels and
on some levels it's really like kind of
old old old white people so with the
exception of Tracy Morgan like you kind
of like they kind of like their black
people to do impressions of other black
people right you know I mean like they
kind of want you to be kind of like
Eddie yeah and if you're not that it's
like you know it's weird
well I'm glad to see chase doing his
thing Shane's doing is they enough day
yeah he's really doing this thing and
actually Leslie's doing her thing so I
mean back then it was everything they
wanted me to do as an impression I'm not
an impressionist I'm you know
impressions are tough compressions are
[ __ ] hard I try to even accents and
impresses outside to do it this is what
am i doing it about Drake impersonation
okay I went to Toronto I went to Atlanta
I used to bleep drink Pepsi but now I
like Fanta
did you see American sniper yeah but you
know what you just have another ski your
skills writing jokes it's like how many
guys can do impressions and write really
good jokes that's Eddie Murphy like one
guy you know
you know Dana Carvey okay to two guys
you know I mean like like how many great
Impressionists can write great jokes not
a lot so you write great jokes you've
seen karyotype live before I have seen
Carrot Top Las Vegas so I'm where I see
Carrot Top imagine you saw Mike back in
the day like at the store like before he
got this biggest row I just saw him not
too long ago when I played by yourself I
didn't see a show but he came back yeah
but he always comes by I like carrot top
he didn't his Vegas show I don't know
why I just thought of carrot top because
we were talking about impressions but I
I saw scare top show in Vegas and I'm
like I don't know why people get us got
so much [ __ ] I don't know why either
he's the greatest prop comic to ever
live and he's got really good jokes in
the show that really that defy probably
like like [ __ ] I had to write
that joke yeah and it's pacing in jizz
the production is well-timed light and
stuff and then you think about what it
takes to day in and day out play Vegas
no no no I mean no no we do we're just
in another I don't know just now we you
know so much hateration and comedy I'm
more of a live and let live yeah just
have fun I got I got no beef with nobody
and I can anybody that's really
successful I could appreciate what's
good about them even though you know
some of this shit's not for me exactly
but it takes something to be able to
connect with a yeah I didn't watch yo
man I've watched Larry the Cable Guy on
The Tonight Show and laughed my ass off
right like oh those are good jokes there
yeah you know even Gallagher I've seen
[ __ ] that makes me laugh right you know
not I'm not with all the watermelon
smashing but
you used to talk about you talk about a
show was that in Chicago I think it was
in Chicago about you were closing out
and the floor was shaken a something and
it was Martin Oh Martin blew me off the
stage in Chicago at the very crown yeah
yeah man yeah they had I was open Martin
was opening for me but it was like I was
on SNL he had one of those things
sometimes the people know you know ever
hear like a record say hit this [ __ ]
just came out Wednesday it's like how's
it already yeah yeah how does everybody
know the words to you know the car DB
already that yeah that song is that song
hit fast you know like Martin was like
that like I don't not even sure the def
jam and premiered yet right you know I
mean it was coming though it was like a
week away and Martin show was like a
week away but somehow people knew that
this [ __ ] was the man like that
[ __ ] was a groundswell and yeah I was in
my dressing room cocky as [ __ ] don't
need to watch my opening acts Chris Rock
well if I earn and that [ __ ] was
killing like it's like you ever hear
like you sitting backstage and you here
are you here reaction I thought it was a
fight or something going on here I come
out just keep my head out people are
just laughing so hard I'm like oh [ __ ] I
getting nervous
yeah it's got get nervous and then you
get like when you get really nervous too
you start accusing the person of
stealing all your bits that's too close
to mine that thing you do about air
traffic controllers is a little too
close to the thing I do about lip balm
know I don't even say lip balm hello sir
he did you know what he's supposed to do
20 he probably did 3540 like you know
Bart do you give a [ __ ] right and I went
out there and I [ __ ] bomb so horribly
that one of those bombs were like okay
uh let me try my closer around fifteen
minutes in said this will get them back
and that [ __ ] don't work and you're just
like oh [ __ ] I got another [ __ ] 30
minutes let's go
dry mouth dry mouth and I'm sweating I
might have still had a jheri curl I
don't know I might have been like the
last remnants of jheri curl guys and me
and Ice Cube fighting it
what is this you to ourselves - I
remember it might have been somebody
else but who I'm sure is [ __ ]
offended right now yeah and didn't I
remember the promoter didn't want to pay
us I don't even know if we got paid that
day [ __ ] yeah I forget the guys name but
I think he was a cop okay say where's
our money is there a problem
okay okay I'm never getting this money
you uh do a bloody big online where you
uh
every time you pulled over I haven't
done it in a while cuz the cops were
like realizing I was doing it okay I
don't need did you pull it over that
outfit
I do get pulled over I remember I'm old
so I've been you get like I think I've
been getting pulled over a long time you
know I'm so I'm Way more as used to it
than you are right yeah I got that it's
like I had money in the thing you know
91 right with a red Corvette and a big
titty white girl
[Laughter]
well that [ __ ] was like dangerous now
nobody cares you got a big-titty white
girl 91 a [ __ ] with a big to the white
girl in a red Corvette red convertible
like like I was really asking for it
yeah I got that really good I guess I
was really asking to get the [ __ ] beat
out of it I'm surprised I did it's the
[ __ ] I got that you saw that I got
the Alfa Romeo I've rented it out for
this app Toro which is you could rent
cars from people and they're not I've
been driving you know I was driving I
don't like this [ __ ] it's too little and
how you can rent a car off an app yeah
off of uh is this apt or you can rent
cars from I guess actually look at your
phone before I leave it's like Airbnb
but for cars Wow so say you know you you
own the road you don't I mean you do
they insure it you want to have somebody
manage one of your cars and you can like
just rent out this for ten days and see
and if people pay I got that for a
hundred and for a day that that car but
goes right to your credit card goes
right to the credit loss and the person
to bring it to you but I don't like that
car because it's just too little and
weird and it just feels is one of those
cars I don't like that attention wears I
always one of those and I just told to
do it I say man come pick this [ __ ] up
please I'll give you two tickets to the
show I don't own a car I'm frugal man
low overhead yeah I got three cars I'm
definitely thinking about getting rid of
one well you got AI got a Porsche
Carrera convertible
I got a G Wagon black-on-black well
brand new and I have a Maserati the
convertible yeah yeah that was a gift
from Sandler grown-ups one yeah and
we do well we did well that's uh that's
a great gift
yeah there's a car see now is just
standard for gifts just skewed now you
can you even appreciate nice bottle wise
like I got a Maserati gift but let's
step it up at least five digits for the
gift yes
[Laughter]
did you just finish filming you just
finished them on a movie
yeah man Sandler just did this thing
called a week of where my son marries
his daughter and hilarity and hilarity
ensues it's got work go art I don't wait
I mean uh y'all do y'all not get along
and don't know we don't know is there
conflict this conflict and then to y'all
we're never really we never become pals
got over it doesn't end off which albeit
pals my baby yeah we'll be in the same
room are you writing you writing some
new movies lurking on a couple of movies
one with all of us then one more top
five ish yeah relationship e yeah it's
got a tour man I just thought I gotta
make some money yes so the movies are
not as lucrative so I just been like
okay yeah let me get into this tour
ahead let me you know I've been supposed
to write a movie for years and I just
haven't you don't have an idea I have
little ideas I don't I don't know if I
have the focus or the that's emergency
it's tough to get the scissors you make
a lot of money already it's yeah it's
the problem with your generation about
you sound like an old man tell me you
guys you make you make good money and
you got you [ __ ] amazing women already
so what why would you write a booby
what's the
that's a solid question it's like you
know I guess is just like like to what
what are you two getting him yes the
only reason is to have the creative
ownership yeah movie that's dying to
come out of you but you guys the world
so much nicer so it's not like you don't
have to make it come out we used to have
to shoot a movie out sometime I gotta
get a movie up and now I'm like what
technology is so easy to just put it
together and get so many people just
buying movies - yeah you live in the
world when they bring out for males to
your house yeah see before I [ __ ] you
know how this [ __ ] barrels see before
bringing alpha Oh males to your [ __ ]
house women cb4 cb4 with a classic sit
so you do you direct it a lot you've
directed a lot just a couple I've
directed the head of state you know I
think I love my wife and top five
specials to them I've directed Amy
Schumer's special which one the one for
HBO oh yeah yeah
director hers so when I direct it right
I think toyed with directing other stuff
what do you how do you direct a special
like what do you you personally watch
the material you know who do I want to
do this you give her some notes mm-hmm
she did all the notes we picked a
bidding USA how about the Apollo she had
some other venue some random [ __ ]
venue it's like okay Paulo that sounds
interesting cuz you wanna do [ __ ] in an
interesting place and you know but most
specials take place in the cut so I mean
you can the problem with most specials
honestly is common
ian's they try to capture the show and
the reality is when you sit there to
edit the special you're creating a whole
new piece of art yeah yeah
so just cuz a joke followed this joke at
the show if that let's see how does it
fit you know you can move [ __ ]
ridiculously heat once you get into edit
so yeah so you know some of it was
helping with the you know she wrote all
the jokes and all that stuff but a lot
of it was just like the the order and
yeah the pacing of it yeah yeah my last
one I definitely moved jokes around but
I sweat it throughout so some people
like what was you sweaty and then that
sweaty every time she got sweaty they
stopped the show really and wipe the
sweat off so it like four times in the
show we had to stop it actually stopped
what do you know what when you add it to
show you don't feel it you don't feel
that problem and at the time I was like
what the [ __ ] going I was mad but when
it was trying to get in there and like
cut [ __ ] looked you know and you have a
literally a joke you know you'd move
things there were 15 minutes apart or
whatever in [ __ ] no it was somebody at
the stage like panicking with a towel
it's like just wave them off because I
don't want to interrupt the flow so I
just kept on it's calm asado comedy kama
sorrows my sweaty especial I don't know
what the hell was makeup it was like a
week and the ceiling crazy food was
happening sticking out of my head the
entire somebody created a Twitter
account call it Hannibal's hair Wow
that's how weird the internet that's
what young folks got a deal with do it
but I will deal with that I'll bring the
pain well [ __ ] was making
making leather suits I'm so glad I've
been able to shut breaking the pains up
black people at [ __ ] [ __ ] do you think
you are I could never do that special
down did you do two shows a night yeah I
did do two shows yeah I could never do
that show now Kilda but I understand you
can't [ __ ] say that [ __ ] bout it
[ __ ] house down they say some of that
[ __ ] the energy in there was that that
captured I mean you say comedians don't
like that captured that show that vibe
was it looked it did you know what it
did capture that show and I don't
remember I wasn't really I'm at I had
notes but I was I didn't really cut cut
that show I cut cut my other shows right
that's I mean I had notes but I didn't
yeah keep Trousdale and sandy channeling
did that special you know yeah great job
well because we they're doing a
documentary on it that come out come on
yeah yeah they talked to me for it so I
rewatched it and it just is this [ __ ] is
kinetic you know it's funny maybe the
next special I think maybe for bigger
and blacker I remember having that DVD
and that's the one that tracks you
walking right right I remember watching
as a newest comedian and for some reason
it might as be my weird specificity or a
slight autism spectrum [ __ ] but you hand
in the person to water I was like that's
what big-time comedy is like oh so you
get famous and then you just hand the
person the water and then you do comedy
like I need to get to hand in pretty
full of water levels yeah you're there
now
[Music]
why
[Music]
[Applause]
are you gonna what song you are you
gonna walk out what you've been walking
out - what have I been walking out -
jay-z what is it you don't know yeah
yeah wasn't there like a dance there's a
little bit there's a little bit of Kanye
ha yeah
ultra light you know breaks into jay-z
so it's good because we're the same age
and reasonable doubt and bringing a pain
came out the same summer oh yeah it's so
I feel I feel a kinship with Jay but
from the same neighborhood but I never
met him but back then when she meets a
meet Jay I met him later I probably met
him at the Chris Rock Show yeah cuz I
stay play he did anything did it all the
time he played like two three times yeah
yeah yeah did hard-knock life did the
[ __ ] was that record what the [ __ ] is
that record 4:00 a.m. we was at the club
tune and we advanced above 7 yeah you
know whatever the [ __ ] that record yeah
don't do it again
like he did that one too a couple I like
that he references that track on a hey
poppy he's safe
no 615 no 615 this year you can stay the
night there's a callback rappers do
callbacks that's a fun thing what you do
you reference older specials every now
and then I do it in this drawer I do I
never really before but this one I'm
just like ok yeah looks like slided a
real quick just so yeah
hey hey we've been doing this a while
come on have fun do you uh
I went to see the [ __ ] in the
Hat hey what was that that's like full
cuz you did how long ever wrong was that
no three months for it was eight twelve
weeks up like that did you go three
weeks not loved it yeah it's the most
fun I ever had
Broadway most fun I've ever had a great
play with funny jokes yeah big laughs
that I didn't even have to write all I
have to do is act everyday
yeah but you do you want or you do it
every day but you've in a different
building yeah but this is like it's a
good story it's a man and what like gets
dramatic every night people are
screaming it was I mean being a hot play
she's unbelievable I may do a play after
this yeah I'm done with the tour yeah
just in you got an idea you look at
Wheaton plays right now and if I find
the right one says I like doing it it's
fun you everything about writing to play
I do but it's hard enough acting in a
play like that [ __ ] like act that ain't
like that actor actor you know I mean
when you're gonna play with Broadway at
those are real actors everybody has kind
of evolved I mean come on Bobby
Cannavale you'll Vasquez Elizabeth
Elizabeth Rodriguez Annabelle er I mean
you act in a movie that you know you
[ __ ] up they go they do it again we got
takes there's no takes on [ __ ]
Broadway right [ __ ] you you got to do
this [ __ ] for real
yeah there's no edit there's no cutting
to the other guy when you're fumbling
your line when your eye when it when
they see you looking up into your head
cuz you don't remember your [ __ ] [ __ ]
plague IV foot on you'll be on so and
hit that's I couldn't that's why I as if
you went crazy because I just you job
due to on Saturdays she's lost a day's
201 say Wednesday met yeah
I see I saw I found this I saw Hamilton
here
Chicago's I took my mom to it and I
think this [ __ ] is really dope is great
it's very entertaining but they got a
rap this [ __ ] every day these same
[ __ ] Thomas Jefferson bars rule it
happen room whatever every [ __ ] day
indefinitely
yeah the same and just nail it and make
it look in it because it's like you know
thing this is well I I'm glad I did that
play because it made top-5 a better
movie household cuz I really kind of
start learning how to act and when you
do a play it's like not only do you got
to learn how to act but it's like what I
used to say is like okay I got to figure
out how to add something new every night
and do the same lines I'm going to
ad-lib every night but physically
physically how I say [ __ ] am I gonna
yell it am I gonna say it you know I
mean like like really [ __ ] with the
lines a little bit and you figure that
out in a play you learn all your moves
it's like oh I couldn't be funny this
way I could be funny that way I can and
then you know do go direct top five
after that with a better understanding
of acting and if you have a better
understanding of acting you have a
better understanding of writing so you
realize you're not just writing a bunch
of jokes you're writing a character so
it's like the play helped me out a lot
when I I'm a corny old man I know one a
director I work with I you talked about
like directing techniques like a couple
times it's been directors I work with
they'll tell the other actor in a TV or
movie set and the other actor to do some
weird [ __ ] or improvise it won't tell me
just to get a real reaction every or
real reaction out to play off of it and
that's pretty it's pretty fun it makes
for some good [ __ ] that do you have any
special techniques you use to get
different performances out of actors not
really it's like be funny you try to
hire funny the funniest [ __ ] I
mean the funny [ __ ] in top five some of
that [ __ ] I had nothing to do it man set
it to entertainer that [ __ ] was all him
he came in with a bunch of ideas it's
like sure let's do it
rock rock rock I got this thing with
hangers manners yeah let's do this thing
I got this thing with the hangers can I
do it sure sure
Cedric like facilitator yeah yeah it's
exact see I'm more filled yeah I'm not
like Mike D'Antoni you don't have to run
my system yeah like good players man let
them let them do what they do what you
think Phil is up to right now Montana
Montana with a bad [ __ ] they broke up
with her smoking bud Montana reading a
book but he's got he just quit before he
got fired because people thought he's
being a weirdo with the porzingis well
people talk about trading porzingis he's
like stop it yeah you've done it yeah
this shut up shut up
the Knicks it's a lot of pressure on
that team but there's not they're not
gonna do anything for probably 15 years
or so
[Music]
we got porzingis Hernandez the center is
pretty good I mean who knows man I don't
know man was the first time you said
course I did again oh man when was the
first time I sat quarts I was a good set
that's a good one um portside quarts a
fetal cuz I remember when I was at SNL I
sit with Lauren and he has really good
seats but they're not courtside
so the first timer is after bringing the
pain man yeah I could bring the pain I
was like this other guy all of a sudden
and I was like this courtside guy yeah
and what's on the screen put me on the
screen I think spike might uh I think
spike mighta invited me that might have
been my first like sitting with him and
then one day you know they started just
sitting me there yeah and I'm forever
grateful for love it I have to bring the
pain you were like considered like the
top dog you know you know when that
special came I was like am I the bigger
blacker yeah
bring the pain was big but bigger and
blacker was actually bigger yeah for
some weird like was two years between oh
yeah like two years between two years
between and yeah two years between I
wasn't even planning on good uh it's
weird I knew a friend of mine manages
Madonna and Guy Guide and Madonna was
supposed to do a special in Cuba suppose
do like one of those music specials and
she canceled at the last minute like
yeah she's not doing it and I kind of
knew how much money she was getting so I
called my manager I wasn't I'm telling
you I wasn't really planning on doing a
special and I said I'll do a special but
I have to get exactly the money she was
supposed to get
and man it's like what the [ __ ] are you
talking about Sam tell them I want
exactly that amount of money and he got
and came back with it
so I'm trying to say before I want to
get too much in the money but maybe I
got 400 grand or whatever before that I
got like 30 grand for bringing fish cuz
that's how much they used to paint
Wow but you knew it's there you don't
really like you like to negotiate
information so there you go it's like
when you're a comedian here's what
happened
when you play colleges we all we all
make money off the student intern
program yeah a student entertainment
budget right but if you have a really
good agent and you're playing towards
the end of the year a good agent will
have some inside information and he'll
know how much money the college still
has in their budget ocean so if they got
a lot of money left in it they have to
spend it the money doesn't go over so
your agent can like it's like your your
$2,000 comic but they got they got
10,000 in their budget and you're doing
a show in May the [ __ ] school year is
almost over
given yeah so that would my mind ago she
ation was basically another version of
that I knew how much they had in a
budget yeah Amy's thing is a little
different but you know how's that it's
good I think
I want to do some after parties I think
you'd leave it I was thinking you know
it was a part of me that's like I should
do the after parties of my tour yeah
that's what I do
probably you can not you know but I'm so
mad I'm you know I'm just too anal and
meticulous so your DJ say would be
perfect yeah yeah because I'd be working
on my DJ set all day too
the same way you see me like working on
these jokes and like die I'm like I have
jokes on a diagram and
I'm listening to the show the night oh
hello in your blood you gotta listen to
last night's show and yeah well that
[ __ ] just go out there and play music
just in your blood you just go out there
play music yelling to Mike a couple
times yeah piece of chicken
$50,000 in lead tallien play cardi B
play some cardi B bomb drop the beat out
you know two words and
shout out some people and then by Cardon
yeah you could buy a car with that [ __ ]
just uncle that app well you know wrap
it up man appreciate your coming let's
show thanks we'll come from so anything
no information no talk of you afterwards
without microphones yes
6:08 Showtime eight doors are selling
yeah doors at 7:00 but thanks man we've
got anything for Hannibal Buress
[Music]
you can write your medal right your
movies you directed I'll direct it you
figured it out this relaxing this is
like this fit that does it does kind of
that makes you think like that kind of
gets ideas flow but yep Thank You Man
being a great mentor the lesson have me
on the show overpaying for over the next
I'm trying to make sure you pick up my
call it's such a better show yeah it's a
good show they're like oh [ __ ] didn't
even pay for Hannibal Burres
we got [ __ ] Hannibal birth to it's
fun sighs [ __ ] the whole tours been that
way yeah people like [ __ ] out of here
Dave talks about I think was it this
Cleveland Show jokes about being just
coming to check you out and then he was
drunk he's like yeah I got booed anyways
Chris Rock Show Golden State is the [ __ ]
like all the goodwill ran out they're
like [ __ ] you and Rick James is a comedy
how quickly you can lose an audience no
matter how much they like you get the
one in the one just yes show you how
fearless David it's like you really
wouldn't have to tell anybody else
that's a bad idea
and Dave doesn't give up yeah I
[Music]